[Applause]
but is that why apple's getting into the
car
i think they just saw what i think
teslas would have proved
that if that you because car companies
before tesla were not
great businesses it's not like people
were rushing to put more money into car
companies because basically it was a low
margin thing and it's very expensive to
fold and bend steel the majority of a
car
is steel that's folded bent and welded
together
yeah that's a low margin expensive
business that takes a lot of capital to
get it to the point where it's efficient
yeah i think what what sort of tesla
showed is that
one people are willing to spend more for
something that's better and there was a
lot of design
disruption there was a lot of
low-hanging design fruit that car
companies had just neglected
off of just tradition and doing things
their own ways
i remember i was on like a panel with it
was like the head of design from
ford and this was this was a while back
when tesla was just getting started and
people were asking about electricity i
just i just don't think electric
cars are real cars and he
was so blinded by his own expertise and
he wasn't wrong he's a very
knowledgeable person about car design
but he wasn't really watching where the
future was going yeah and that's why
tesla very quickly had a stock price
that was worth like the next 10
auto companies combined yeah and i think
that's what apple saw is that sort of
stock price and that ability to create
you don't you don't think that they see
valuable screen time yes within your car
now it's another point to collect sort
of data and and
but also affinity with the other
platforms but also think about it
as we move towards self-driving all of a
sudden
you will have unbothered screen time
in your car right do you want that to be
on a tesla screen
or do you want that to be on an apple
screen that's the really interesting
thing right so
that's what i thought it was combined
with one other thing and i'm curious
about your take on this
apple are let's say they're the masters
of battery life
the biggest inhibitor to electric car
use from the average consumer outside of
price
is battery life well i can't go visit my
grandparents or five hours away i gotta
stop two times
if they're the best at battery life and
they can
solve that problem plus they get to be
part of this extra screen as we go into
the
era of driverless cars or self-driving
cars
don't they want to be yeah and it's also
a thing like where
if you own a apple laptop you're more
likely to get iphone because
same type of interface yes compatibility
yes and so if you have an apple laptop
that is the majority of your work the
rest of your work is done through your
iphone and then getting an apple car
that extends that sort of office to your
commute
kind of makes sense right it's like all
the same messaging you're going with
seamlessly with your conversation
through them all
yep it kind of makes sense i mean i
would probably get
an apple car if they made one i'm not
like a huge
car guy i kind of looked them as like
what's functional transportation so if
it was more seamless with the things i
use a lot of i would get it but you
don't drive to work every day for a half
an hour
no i don't drive to work every day for
half an hour but i'll
either uber or i would take the subway
back home yeah
that's phone time for me yeah apple has
my screen time
yeah now that the commute is going to be
phone time they
have to yeah for the good of their
business
it i mean i look at this no different
than like uh the fuji nokia thing have
you heard about that story
when fuji bought the 92 olympics or
something
they bought the rights for like the 92
olympics and that was what shrunk the
moat
enough for like fuji to become equal of
equal standing to nokia this is back
when we film cameras when i'm speaking
to the millennials right now they have
no [ __ ] clue what i'm talking about
but
in other words they're like certain
moments in history where you let someone
approach your market share
and without even seeing it you don't
recognize that now that's your biggest
competitor
and i think that apple's super smart to
get in there because we're going to
spend
spend significant time in our cars and
then we get super comfortable with this
tesla screen
if tesla comes out of the phone we're
like well [ __ ] i want my phone to be
like my car screen
i'm in my car for an hour a day some
people driving an hour a day matter of
fact
how many more people would be willing to
drive if
one they don't even have to find parking
they could send the car home eventually
you'll just be able to send the car home
right there won't be any parking drive
me to work send it home come pick me up
when i'm ready
yeah i tend to think that that's farther
away so this is how i look at like the
self-driving car
thing is walk down the street of sort of
like a mixed income neighborhood
yeah and look at all the cars and find
the car that's the oldest
and like what is the average age of
those cars okay
so even once we get to the point where
there are new fully capable self-driving
cars
it'll be a ways beyond that point where
we see full adoption of them
meaning that if we walk down the street
of like the the airbnb you're staying
out in florida you'll see cars that
might be 15 years old
right we'll see some early 2000s yeah
models like pickup trucks and stuff like
that mixed in with some brand new cars
so it's going to be a ways before
there's actually fully saturated amount
of these brand new self-driving car so
if you look at this example of your
street even once we have the car
available we'll still be seeing for the
next 15 years
cars that don't have that availability
i'm going to give you a little bit of
pushback
every time you see a huge technological
jump i feel like it expedites that
transition
so for example the flip phone to the
smartphone
right you could not be seen with a
[ __ ] flip phone when everybody had a
smartphone it didn't have to be an
apple phone maybe it was an android
maybe it was a blackberry or something
like that but you need to have a [ __ ]
smartphone
and i feel like if we go self-driving or
if we go electric whatever that
transition is once it becomes
ubiquitous if you had a 15 year old car
you're going to find the cheapest
[ __ ] electric car and get on board
because
the longest you've owned the phone
though for great point
yeah great point the obsolescence of a
phone is is a much higher thing
yeah the i think the concept is true but
i think the
the the turnover rate of cars is slower
than phones
yeah absolutely i'm probably on a new
phone like every eight months because i
drop them and break them or yep yep no
no that's a great point the turnover
went on for
yeah i'm just i'm super curious i'm
super curious about it man
it's interesting when you look back in
time and looked at how we predicted
so incorrectly where we'd be
technologically wise one of my favorite
things to do is to look at old articles
on the future of fashion and they're
asking people that are experts in
fashion in these kind of trends and
textiles and all this stuff
yeah yeah and whenever they like you
know you look at like the 1960s what
will people be wearing
in like the 2000s and it was all like
spandex
meanwhile we're still wearing denim like
we still wear jeans
and that's what i'm really curious about
we do wear spandex well we wear all of
it
well here's what happens right jeans
denim makes no sense as a fabric in
today's thing we can make such high-tech
space-age fabrics that like wick away
moisture
that cool that have plenty of like ball
like we can do all this sort of
innovative stuff with fabrics
but still jeans are the most dominant
pant
yeah but what's happened is it's not
that we've replaced
denim this antiquated material we just
slowly infect it with ten percent of
spandex
five percent lycra make it a little
stretchier we got sketchy jeans you know
a little more
a little more room and then that's the
way i think technology really happens
it's not quite as
completely tabula rasa clear the decks
total revolution it's this little
infection and then that changes this
other ripple
yeah so i look at it in like furniture
woodworking and design
so for so long it used to be that the
the
signature of a talented woodworker was
if you could make a board flat
if you could make a board flat with like
an axe and like something that looks
like a shovel but sharper like
you were really [ __ ] good at what you
do yeah all of a sudden we create
machines that can do that effortlessly
and the woodworker is just like [ __ ]
and then what happens you know what
happens flat boards become
everywhere and then you know what like
sort of interior designs go you don't
want flat boards
you're describing jeans right right yeah
yeah and so
even as we technologically progress we
go well i don't know if i like this new
technology i mean like joggers are more
comfortable
yeah like it makes sense to always wear
like stylish looking sweatpants yeah
thank god that we've created a more
forgiving aesthetic that allows us to
wear these in public
but at the same time you're kind of like
ah this looks a little too
a little too spacey i gotta i gotta pull
back and look a little more classic
culture is undefeated man
it's like we've been wearing the same
suits we've changed the material a
little bit
right we've been wearing the same suit
for the last 200 300 years probably
when did the suit get invented two
mit 200 after the powdered wigs died
down
they only have really one uncomfortable
thing at a time yeah
yeah so it's like the fact that like i
mean i bet you look into japanese
culture where they're
still wearing you know some of the same
outfits they say but they've they've
shifted the fabrics
yeah you know the the wooden clogs
they're similar
but maybe it's a little bit more
lightweight wood yeah but maybe they're
a little bit more comfortable there's
certain things they're going to do to
make [ __ ] a little bit better a little
bit more easy for us to get along with
today
it's it's really interesting what sort
of design jeans are sticking around
that's american [ __ ] pants here's
here's my sort of question
and i don't know the answer to this but
it's like do you think
if you ask somebody will we be wearing
jeans a thousand years from now or
most people are like i don't think so
we'll probably come up with something
new
but if you break it down being like will
we wear jeans 100 years from now
not all of us but like will they still
be yes at least thirty percent of pants
yes
yeah 100 and then if they make it that
long which will clearly have way more
advanced
fiber technology i mean look at how fast
our sort of textiles have gone
why wouldn't they make it another
hundred and then it's like well [ __ ] you
can't
we can't break up with jeans invest in
[ __ ] jeans
so it's uh that's that's how i tend to
think about
like uh self-driving cars and all this
kind of stuff
is we'll see it in like it'll definitely
be a part of society but a lot of times
we were wrong about how completely
and dominantly it takes over yeah and
even with like the internet and back to
that sort of point about the internet
has just
disrupted things yeah we've been seeing
that with like with like
television as we know it cable
television is declining
but what's happening in the pandemic is
like it's not like it goes away and it
dies it just sort of merges and becomes
this
mesh of like stuff right so like what is
hbo max now yeah like it's a tv channel
that's still on some cable packages
yeah it's also this like netflix
alternative with
really good content it's also a
publishing house of like
really well-made shows it's a bunch of
things and it's in this awkward
point of like coming together this is
what it is it's uh chinese immigrants
come to america they open up a chinese
restaurant
americans try the food they're like this
is too chinese
right like what the [ __ ] is going on
here so then
you have hbo max where it's like okay
some of this is still
on regular paid cable this is also
streaming so now you have like the
chinese food that's
somewhat reflective of the chinese
culture but also somewhat reflected of
the american one right
and youtube or instagram or whatever
these things are
is basically the chinese-american food
where if a chinese person tried it
they'd be like
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is or
pizza yeah
pizza is not italian anymore it's
american it is
yeah you're welcome america so we're
watching the evolution sometimes it
happens a little bit faster sometimes
happens a little slower
maybe elon is an amazing marketer and
that's why we all think that electric
cars are going to be a thing i
i wonder what happens when like
i wonder what happens when these other
car companies get involved i don't know
if it was you was talking to but it was
somebody
that said um the competitive advantage
that tesla has
is not necessarily the tech because
he's made the tech open source so
everybody can use the tech
but the data in order to was it you i
was talking about this
a little bit yeah so i think there's a
few advantages that tesla has
i think the most important one now is
access to cheaper capital
so let's say real quick before we get
into the money thing
the uh this is an ai thing some i don't
know if it was you was talking or
somebody
they basically said like tesla every
person that drives a tesla is feeding
information back into that ai and that
ai is
is that computer learning is happening
and is better navigating the streets
so all these new electric cars that pop
up aren't going to have as good
self-driving because they don't have 20
years or how 10 years how long has tesla
been around now
about 10 10 years so they don't have 10
years of people driving
so volkswagen is going to have its first
you know self-driving car you have one
year of data good luck
you might bump into some [ __ ] so what
tesla's well situated
is to have an advantage along with
companies like google too because
google's been doing a lot of stuff in
this space yeah yeah yeah
so like i think one of the i've recently
become more involved with ai startups so
i'm now on the
advisory board for two different ai
companies yeah and what what i've
learned and i'm by no means an expert in
this technology i'm just trying to get
my head around it and
be part of sort of the the public face
of helping them with some initiatives
but what's interesting is it's not that
like you create this brain and that's
the genius it's not like the man's
scientist i created this frankenstein
computer brain that's really smart
it's trial and error what you're
figuring out is this is the most
efficient way
to create software that can learn
through machine learning yeah
so it's creating the simplest thing that
benefits over time
with more data being added to it is how
do we how do we grow
intelligence yeah more than how do we
create intelligence yeah
it's really finding what's the efficient
path with the least amount of
undesirable outcomes
to slowly grow as we add more data input
into this device or piece of software so
in order for
volkswagen or porsche or one of these
companies to have an efficient
ai self-driving system they need that
data and if they haven't been put
through all these different situations
that tesla cars have over the last 10
years
they're not going to be as efficient and
making the decision that needs to be
made to save your life
just yet right right so maybe that's the
huge advantage and maybe that's why
when all these other cars pop up onto
the market you're gonna notice
an even bigger bump for tesla because
once you try the vw you're like
dude i don't even trust it all right but
think about this way no i won't
it's an advantage but you know what else
is an advantage owning waze
who owns waze google who owns all the
mapping things and that's why like apple
and google are always
arguing about like whose map is default
on
your phone so apple has their own
mapping thing which is getting
information about people's driving past
so it's like
if you have your iphone and you're using
your apple map app to like give yourself
directions as you
drive your very nice g wagon congrats
yeah rentals but whatever
thank you thank you very much shout out
to 60. yeah i appreciate
fif you again g wagon not the amg but
it's all good
they're getting data about where you're
finding traffic in miami they're getting
they're getting data on your your routes
to and from
your sort of a very short commute so
they're getting information too
it's not as pure tesla's probably
getting more per user but there's way
more users there's way more iphones in
existence they're getting used for
traffic navigation than there are tesla
cars yeah and then when you look at like
what google has with google maps and
ways they're getting a bunch of stuff
as well so that's kind of like the sort
of informational war and no one has like
a clean
singular advantage but they're all
trying to do it in kind of different
ways and that's what's sort of fun to
watch is
what's going to be more valuable in the
end i have no idea is it going to be
having the complete data set from
actually owning the data coming out of
the car itself
or is the mix of seeing how you behave
in new york
versus miami when you're using public
transportation mixed in with
vehicular transportation that might end
up proving more advantageous
yeah and that's what that's the beauty
of ai is you have a system that can
crunch all this data
and and keep surfacing discoveries yeah
[Applause]
right
you